what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and today I'm going to be
talking about tower of God a new anime
that I enjoyed so much that it couldn't
even wait for the weekly episodes and
immediately started reading the original
webcomic I haven't completely caught up
yet and here I'm gonna be focusing
primarily on what's been covered up in
the anime so far but I hope to make even
more videos about Tower of God when I'm
all caught up if you do want to see more
Tower of God content on this channel
make sure to smash that like button to
let me know if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future tower of god videos if you
are interested in philosophy you can
check out our other channel philosophy
and motion link in the description where
we regularly talk about life changing
philosophies leave any suggestions for
future tower of god videos in the
comments and without further ado let's
jump into it right away the philosophy
of this story caught me off guard
usually we start stories following a
specific character but here before that
we're addressed personally we are told
that money and wealth honor and pride
authority and power revenge or something
that transcends all these whatever you
desire is here here referring to the
tower itself the idea behind the tower
is that if you can get to the top you
can get anything you want or desire that
in and of itself is a fascinating idea
in modern society we're often told
usually in subliminal ways that buying
this or that product will give us
happiness although when we get what we
wanted whether it's an expensive car or
a huge house or high-end shoes those
things usually become the new normal
soon enough our overall happiness
doesn't really change except now we're
probably in a worse position because we
spent all of our money and we're in debt
and as a result might be trapped in a
job that we don't like because we're
living paycheck to paycheck so as we're
trying to become more happy through
purchases or by other external means we
might be actually digging ourselves
deeper and deeper into an unhappiness
trap if we look for our happiness in
external things like money power over
others what other people think about us
and so on there will always be something
else to desire the truth is if you can't
be happy now you probably won't be happy
in
future because a you may die before you
achieve your goals B you might realize
how empty you feel after accomplishing
them and as a result might quickly move
on to the next goal and see by constant
looking for happiness in the future and
design what you don't have you're
actually wiring your brain to always
look for happiness elsewhere in this way
people become slaves to their desires
forever chasing happiness without ever
really experiencing it the Tower of God
is pretty much our desires on steroids
it presents itself as being able to
fulfill anybody's desire no matter who's
and no matter how big in other words the
tower is supposed to be something that
can grant anyone happiness in reality
though people come to the tower to get
something but in most cases they end up
losing everything they had things that
they might have taken for granted until
it's too late
thus it's very similar to how us
desiring to keep up with the Joneses in
the modern world can lead us down a
death spiral where we end up in a much
worse position than we were initially in
part of what good art like Tower of God
does in my view is it helps us see our
own faults with more clarity so that we
can live a better life in the real world
one of the things terribly emphasizes is
taking the things we have for granted
while seeking what we don't have or in
other words assuming the grass is always
greener on the other side the story
isn't just talking to us the readers in
the beginning as I ate it it's
communicating with us throughout even
the fact that Rachel wanted to move up
the tower so that she could see the real
endless sky with its countless stars
begs us to examine ourselves and how we
take such things for granted if you're
anything like me you probably take the
beautiful night sky for granted most
nights because it's always there
you can go days weeks or even months
without appreciating it in contrast we
may be mesmerized by a huge mansion or
expensive car because it's not something
we can afford on autopilot we tend to
undervalue what we have an over value
what we don't but the author of power of
God is asking us to re-evaluate things
for a second look at Rachel look how
driven she is to see the real open sky
the sense of freedom that comes with
such a view especially if you've never
seen it before for her and everyone else
in that
world the sky would be more impressive
and they pay more to see it than any car
in the same way we shouldn't assume that
taking a date to a super expensive
restaurant that we can't afford is
better than going to a picnic nearby for
a fraction of the price as the
philosopher Epictetus said wealth
consists not in having great possessions
but in having few wants and quote in
other words if you want true wealth and
happiness it's better to count your
blessings rather than always dwell on
what's missing that doesn't mean you
shouldn't pursue any goals but you
should pursue them happily while
appreciating what you have along the way
and you should be okay with the
possibility of not achieving a specific
goal your happiness should not be tied
to external outcomes that are outside of
your complete control give it your best
shot if it's something that means a lot
to you but realize that the destination
for everyone is death so there's no
excuse for not enjoying the journey I
think there are problems with the
protagonist Baum's philosophy too but
what sets him apart from most other
people in the story is that he didn't
want to go to the tower Rachel wanted
more but Baum was good he spent his life
in a dark cave and he was happy because
Rachel came to visit him every so often
Baum didn't need a harem or money or
power he was happy with the way things
were even though most people watching
this video probably can't imagine being
happy if they were stuck in a dark cave
for as long as they could remember it
wasn't enough for Rachel and she even
got to leave the cave she desired more
and so did the countless people that
continued to try to climb up the tower
Baum isn't a conventional Shonen
character whose main goal is to become
the best or the strongest in the world I
pointed this out about Demon Slayer 2
where Tanja rose desire was to save
Natsuko not to be the number one Demon
Slayer in the world Baum similarly was
happy with what he had even if it wasn't
much and prioritized human connection
rather than money power fame and so on
unfortunately for him rachel is known as
Zuko and she clearly doesn't want to be
saved
here lies Baum's problem simple is not
the answer just like money and fame are
external things that can easily bring
you misery if you completely tie your
happiness to them Baum will stay unhappy
if he continues to tie as happiness
a girl that wants nothing to do with him
anymore here's another relevant quote
from Epictetus it's not what happens to
you but how you react to it that matters
end quote we should empathize with bomb
after all it's hard when you love
someone and just want to be with them
and they want something else however he
can't control Rachael's feelings and
should ultimately let go
instead of being unhappy and
jeopardizing his life and other lives
while chasing Rachel he should
appreciate the new friends around him
like coolin and rock and the girls who
actually like him and are willing to
chase after him too through watching and
reading Tower of God I'm constantly
reminded to actually look her out on my
own life and reevaluate what's most
important to me and what I might be
taking for granted
so in conclusion start looking for
reasons to be happy for what you've got
rather than dwelling on what you don't
enjoy the journey as you take steps
towards your external goals and please
do yourself a favor and don't sit after
a girl who clearly doesn't want you and
that is it for this video let me know
what you thought about it and let me
know how your liking Tower of God if you
did get value from this video I want to
see more like it make sure to smash that
like button and let me know and follow
philosophy in motion linked in the
description for more philosophy videos
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future power of God videos lastly
the YouTube ad rates have significantly
dropped recently so the help and support
we're getting from our anime uproar
patrons is now more important than ever
a very special thank you goes to our
patrons over on patreon who help us
survive these YouTube issues and who
helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost I want to
thank the legend acknowledged by Lord
tweto himself Efrain a and the one to
your patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans steven and radha aloha autumn the
world stealers tyson Corino
acquire respect potato Jonathan King
deci d brandon of aisles and emperor
otaku and our pro hero to your patrons
the one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson king zelgius Anatole
kazansky angel Cruz I Sparky 65 cricket
XP Ted no Ted Jo Stanton very good
Alysha actor innamal 69 jessica calif on
he no commie and water bonnie park so dr
12 rothwyn de hora pn wong mich loves
anime and jccc waka thank you all so
much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon calm
an Emir or and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll even get access to
a private patient only discord where we
talked about anime life and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
slash anime up for link in the
description if you're interested you can
also now join the YouTube channel and
support more content that way if you
prefer whichever way you choose to
support us you can get the same great
benefits thanks again and until next
time see us bass Cowboys
[Music]